so maybe very much to your surprise I
will mainly not speak about Iraq and our
work in in that country but rather on
museums public museums are acculturation
cept developed circuit 250 years ago the
idea to make public the formerly private
collections many of the Kings or noble
private persons first was developed in
Great Britain and France than Italy
Russia and Germany the special focus on
national museums is strongly connected
to the creation of modern nations in the
course of the 19th century National
Museums presented the treasures of a
nation and by presenting artifacts from
foreign cultures in an edition and that
and they documented the political
interests and power place of the time
the interest as well as the presentation
of the capacity to own to document to
decipher or to scholarly link the
cultures of the others to the own one
was a power play in itself so
collections of beautiful precious
strange or scientifically important
historical objects were brought back
home and presented to the curious public
Napoleon's expedition to Egypt was both
a military and a campaign of scientific
curiousness and self presentation the
British Museum already in the first half
of the 19th century presented Assyrian
art to the public means artifacts coming
from Mesopotamia today's Iraq monuments
like the Egyptian obelisks were erect
re-erected in the growing capitals of
that time and structured the modern
urban setting by proudly presenting them
during the end of the 19th century the
Ottoman Empire followed to present
itself as a modern and powerful nation
through the installation of a National
Museum in Istanbul when World War one
ended and the following years of wars in
the Middle East led to several new
states such as modern Turkey Iraq Syria
Palestine nation-building became an
important issue in that region as well
under the Mandate of France in Syria and
Lebanon national museums were founded in
Beirut and Damascus and under the
Mandate of Great Britain the same took
place in bath that in 1926 these museums
mainly collecting and presenting
archaeological artifacts from all over
the respective countries were meant to
preserve and to present the glorious
past of the new nations usually by
skipping more recent centuries and very
much focusing on pre-islamic periods
this idea of national museums has an
impact until today not only are these
museums still the main museums of the
respective countries presenting the best
of the best of objects they are the
treasure halls of the Capitals serve as
a focal point for politicians for
instance when hosting guests and usually
are the major point of interest for
tourists in addition they are connected
to the national antiquities Department
departments means to those
administrative bodies that handle all
archaeological and historical remains of
the countries all objects have to be
delivered there will be documented and
registered there and either will be
stored completely in the magazines of
the national museums or as it is the
case in Syria and Iraq can be
distributed to regional museums
following the educational concepts
developed by the Department of
Antiquities this very centralized system
has the consequence that either only in
the capital or sometimes in major
regional centers people will be able to
see the movable remains of the his
dream in Iraq for instance it was the
rule until 2003 that the national museum
would send some objects on loan to
region regional museums according to the
education concept these were objects
from our periods and all regions of Iraq
by this explaining the historical
development and contribution to mankind
of all Iraq but explicitly not the
regional peculiarities for
administrative purposes as well as under
the aspects of security of professional
documentation and preservation of the
object objects this centralized system
is of course perfect and allows for
effective handlink at least as long as
the magazines are not to jam packed the
centralization of cultural heritage
however has severe impact on the
approach of the normal inhabitant of a
country from three design yrs of
excavations experience in Iraq and
Lebanon I learned how interested people
even in the smallest village are to
understand what we are doing why
archaeological excavations are carried
out why this matters for the region and
especially for the local people one
major question usually is what this
might contribute to the personal
traditions and origin as soon as we
invest into in the involvement of local
people such as extensive information to
our workmen and site guards are in
storytelling in the neighborhood not to
forget in answering questions to the
children the reaction is sympathy and
pride about what can be found in the
home region and how it contributed to
history a recent example in barrel bag
where I am working as well in Lebanon is
we've found there last year another huge
stone block in the Roman quarry known
where blocks of 2 20 meter length and 4
by 4 meters section that way around 10
1000 tons now an even larger stone from
the same period was found fully
preserved in the quarry that weighs at
least 1,600 tons of course superlatives
are attractive in this case literally
half of the town and people from all
social and religious groups came along
not to only have a look on this
superlative but to discuss how this
block was moved in the time of the Roman
Empire and how the people of the town
contributed another example are the
information panels that leaflets for
instance that the Cairo department over
of our Institute's produces produce in
Arabic especially addressing the
neighborhood of excavation sites but
usually archaeology or the random
finding of objects for the local people
is connected to governmental power to
police security offices and Secret
Service institutions that collect these
objects and store them away in the
National Museum in many cases it cases
it is in addition connected to the
activities of criminal persons and
mafia-like entities being active in the
loading and illegal selling of artifacts
so under normal circumstances the topic
is connected negatively and contributes
to the feeling that the governmental
institutions act against the local
societies in case a political system
disappears like the Saddam regime in
2003 or the Mubarak regime in Egypt in
2011 people act against the governmental
institutions and among other actions
destroy or load the museums it is
therefore no wonder that for instance
with a progressing federalization of
Iraq more and more regional and even
local museums are found it since long
the German archaeological Institute
dude and most of its depart departments
are based in its host countries are
focusing on excavation and conservation
projects and so the German
archaeological Institute in
collaboration with its local partners
invests into the involvement of local
entities and in the same time in the
professional commitment of local
scholars members of departments of
Antiquities in museums this is not only
this not only is organized through the
involvement of local staff into our
excavations and research projects but
also in the advanced training of young
scholars and technical stuff such as
excavation technicians conservatives of
archaeological monuments and artifacts
or in the development of school
materials these trainings are organized
in short to mid-term programs that
preferably take place in our host
countries or as is in the case of Iraq
for the time being at least in summer
programs in billing some of them are
connected to international institutions
and our training courses taking place in
all Near Eastern countries topics are
usually advanced methods and techniques
of documentation preservation and
theoretical background learning by doing
and all aspects of scientific approaches
all programs for the time being a kept
low level and often take place without
public announcement the main reason is
the safety of our young trainees who
come from a country or from regions we
are highlighting contacts to foreign
missions to publicly might endanger
their lives in addition we invest into
the digitization of our documentation we
collected through the seniors of
archaeological research such as Maps
plans photographs written documentation
for instance in the so-called Syrian
Heritage browser carried out in
cooperation
with a museum of islamic art in berlin
and with the support of the German
Foreign Office or in other cases the
digital documentation of monuments and
objects by this much easier than in the
past information can be duplicated and
shared with professionals and in cases
of total destruction at least the
detailed documentation with high
probability will survive all sectors
involvement of locals investment into
local information measures training of
young scholars and the digitized
digitization projects need to be
extended we need to enhance the
commitment of all for it as for instance
UNESCO is promoting since lung only with
a widespread education not only in the
fields of archaeology and history we
will be able to preserve the rich
diversity of cultures and the cultural
heritage of our world thank you very
much